i know this night is bittersweet for you
all because you're missing um
part of the the soul of this of this
show
michael callie kenneth williams yeah
i was um i heard that you guys wanted to
honor him that you maybe had some pins
made you wanted to do something let's
see oh that's beautiful
i love that so much what was the thought
behind just wanting to do this just
wanting to have a little piece of
something here to remind everyone to
remind us that there was supposed to be
someone here with us
absolutely yeah he is here with us you
know he's here in spirit i can feel him
in little moments and
and his work is just so profound in
everything that he's done but
particularly what he brought to montrose
was just so special and brave and so
it's just our way of honoring him it was
a wonderful post that you put up so
heartfelt so lovely but i do want to
celebrate you because this is a
celebration for you to sis
come on lead actress in a drama
thank you
and i know how exciting it was but let
me ask misha when you heard
her name called for a nomination what
were you
i was just incredibly excited you know i
was the first person to be like
you know because i don't i just feel
like we've been on this journey together
for a bit now and so it was just
to have the show nominated to have you
nominated
y'all may not be able to say it but i'll
say whoever decided not to bring this
series back i swear
okay i just said it you didn't have to
say it i said it i said it listen it
really it changed a lot of the way that
we looked at television and you know
like
horror noir is something that we never
really got to see i never got to see
growing up and then we got to see it in
a meaningful way with a lot of meat to a
story brilliant she's brilliant anyway
but brilliant
i mean
yes that is exactly what she is that is
exactly what you are for sure all right
so how much fun are you guys gonna have
tonight too because you do have a lot of
celebrating to do and we're hoping that
we can celebrate michael k williams as
well in hearing his name called too yes
hell yeah i mean that would just be so
special for us i mean i think
you know um in honor of michael we plan
to dance
because that's what he did so well
and you know there's something about the
way michael lived his life and the
amount of joy that he brought to all our
lives
that
we want to celebrate tonight can i ask
you about black canary the standalone
film
you need to ask this one come on uh
don't turn away i actually don't know
much because
she's right she's not telling the truth
you know she ain't telling the truth
okay so listen i know you're going to
bring the heat misha
mm-hmm
because listen you know she's going to
bring the heat you don't even understand
you're trying to get us a troll
no never i do but i do want to know a
little something always what can what
what can we tell them
i feel like i want you to say it so you
could get in trouble for it
it's coming how about that yes all right
coming we're very excited about it thank
you all so much beautiful who are you
both of you wearing dior
and bulgari
christian siriano good stuff great
thanks have a great night tonight guys
thank you so much
you